Let's talk about impeachment briefly.
Um, support for impeaching.
Donald Trump has spiked to 41%, but I want
to go through this carefully because there
are different things that impeachment could
mean.
As you probably all know by now, because I
keep mentioning it, impeachment is not the
removal of the president.
Impeachment is the process whereby the house
says we believe the president should be removed
for these reasons and we are filing articles
of impeachment.
It then is up to the Senate to vote, to convict
and remove the president.
And these are two different processes and
a lot of people are interchangeably using
the word impeachment to mean either started
impeachment inquiry, file articles of impeachment
in the House, go through the investigative
process of impeachment in the House and actually
vote to remove Trump in the senate.
But those are for different things.
Okay.
There's a new CNN poll conducted by SSRS,
which says that 41% of the country now wants
Donald Trump impeached and removed from office.
It's good that they're asking the question
in that way.
Now this is actually not the record high for
Donald Trump's presidency.
The same pole back in September had 47% of
the country wanting Trump impeached in December.
43% of the country wanted Donald Trump impeached
and removed, and it dropped into the mid thirties
and now it's back up to 41% the most important
takeaway is that this is a lot.
It's not normal that 41% of the country wants
the president to be impeached and removed,
and not surprisingly, the recent rise in those
numbers is driven primarily by Democrats and
some centrist Independence Democrats.
Now, 76% support impeaching Donald Trump.
That's up eight points from April, so this
tells us a few important things.
Number one, it's just not normal for more
than 40% of the country to believe the president
should be impeached.
Even during the hyperpartisan and sanity of
the Obama Administration, the highest impeachment
support ever for Barack Obama was 33% even
for Bill Clinton who was impeached, impeachment
support never surpassed 30% if I recall correctly,
the current president has 41% impeachment
and removal support.
That is massive.
Number two, support for impeachment, especially
among Democrats and independents, seems to
be correlated with the number of prominent
Democratic lawmakers who are calling for impeachment
proceedings.
Now, we don't know for sure if national support
for impeachment is going up because more prominent
Democrats are calling for impeachment.
I don't know if more prominent Democrats are
calling for impeachment because they see that
more Americans are supporting it, so I don't
know about which way the causation goes, if
any, but it's a trend that's rising in parallel.
They're correlated.
At least this is the most important thing
to understand here.
Do not let the Trump administration and right
wing media trick you into believing that it's
no big deal that 41% of the country wants
Trump impeached.
Impeachment of a president of the United States
has happened only I believe three times in
the more than 240 years that the United States
has been a country.
That 41% support doing that is rare.
And I believe that as more facts come out,
if more Americans read the Mueller report,
if an impeachment inquiry starts, which Bernie
Sanders is now calling for, I'll talk about
that after the break.
The 41% number is going to go up.
And what the Trump administration is going
to insist on is this is just partisan nonsense.
It's partisan, bad, angry democrats.
Once you get to 45% 47% 48% mathematically
it cannot be just partisan democrats.
So do not let them trick you into thinking
that this is no big deal.
This is a big deal.
There've been three impeachments in American
history.
I hope I'm getting that number right.
Um, and that more than 40% of the country
wants that done to the current president is
a massive, massive deal.
We'll be posting a poll question about this
on the David Pakman show Instagram page.
Please follow us there at David Pakman show,
and also please follow me on Instagram at
David Dot.
Pacman.
I am heading to Los Angeles.
After today's program,
the show, I will announce why and I do believe
it's the type of trip where you will want
to be following me on Instagram at David Dot
Pak,